[موسيقى]
ضجه في بريطانيا بعد اختفاء عشرات الاطفال
بظروف غامضه رساله قاسيه على قبر شخص
مديون تثير جدلا واسعا في مصر بعدما وبخته
والدته مسؤول ياباني يعتذر لظهوره واضعا
يديه في جيبيها هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها
لكم من قناه العربيه اهلا بكم
ضجه كبيره احدثها عشرات الاطفال من طالبين
في بريطانيا بظروفه انباء عن اختطافهم من
قبل عصابات الاجراميه تحقيق لصحيفه
الجاردن كشف ان الاطفال خطوط فوق من شارع
خارج الفندقيه وزاره الداخليه البريطانيه
بمدينه
ولم يتم العثور على اغلبهم حتى الان في ما
وصفت وزيره الداخليه في حكومه الظل تابعه
لحزب العمال
الامر بانهم مروع وفضيحه داعيه الحكومه
الى الكشف عن عدد الاطفال الذين اختفوا
وما الذي يتم فعله للعثور عليه
في حادثه اثارت استنكار واسعا في لبنان
القى مجهولون قنبله على محطه تلفزيونيه
خلال بثها برنامج مباشره على الهواء وذلك
بسبب مقطع كوميدي اثر استياء بعض
المواطنين وسائل الاعلام افادت بان
القنبله استهدفت مبنى قناه الال بي سي
والدمفجارها الى في موقف السيارات ادى الى
احداث اضرار ماديه في المكان وفي السيارات
المتواجده هناك مشيره الى ان الحادث اتى
بعد بث مقطع سكيتش في برنامج فكاهيه على
القناه اثار العديد من الانتقادات اذا
اعتبر انه يسخر من لهجه اللبنانيين الشيعه
فيما اطلقت التهديدات ضد البرنامج
والقائمين عليه بالاذان والقتل بحقهم
الى مصر هذه المره حيث ضجت مواقع التواصل
خلال ساعات الماضيه بصوره لرساله قاسيه
على قبر متوفى تشير الى انه لم يقضي دينه
وان مقرضه لن يسامحه ابدا صاحب الدين كتب
على الورقه الموضوع على قبر الشخص المتوفي
لي عندك وفي ذمتك 6000 دولار الله يجعلها
حديد ونار على جسدك ورفقا بالورقه صوره
اقرار مواقع يثبت اخذ المتوفي هذا المبلغ
بتاريخ 20 من اغسطس عام 94 فيما اثارت
صوره الرساله حاله من الجدل على السوشيال
ميديا الثباينه الاراء بين مدافع عن حق
المقرض وبين من يحثثه على المسامحه
اقدم طباخ سوري الاصل وصديقها الذي يحمل
الجنسيه الرومانيه على قتل المليونيره
بريطانيه تبلغ من العمر 71 عاما داخل
منزلها الواقع في شمال لندن
كشفت ان الشاب السوري خنقه السيده التي
تدعى لويس كام والبالغه من العمر 71 عاما
وضعاه جثتها في سله للمهملات خارج منزلها
لتعفر الشرطه عليها بعد ثلاثه ايام واشارت
الصحيفه الى ان الجاني حاول خداع الضحيه
بتعبيره عن حبه لها على امل ان توقع له
على توكيل ليدير ممتلكاتها العقاريه لكنها
رفضت فيما يواجه المتهمين الان احكاما
بالسجن مدى الحياه
وفي خبرنا الاخيره اعتذر مسؤول يابانيون
بارز عن وضعيه يديه في جيبيها خلال رحله
الرسميه الى الولايات المتحده مصرحا بان
والدته وبخته بسبب ذلك له انها خجلت منه
لفعلته هذه صحيفه الجاردين اوضحت ان سكي
كهارى الذي يشغل منصب نائب رئيس مجلس
الوزراء ذكر في مقطع فيديو على يوتيوب ان
والدته قرا التعليقات تنتقص من والديها
وسوء تربيته لها بعد ان التقطته الكاميرات
وهو واضح يديه في جيبي بنطلونها اثناء
حديث رئيس الوزراء بمؤتمر صحفي في واشنطن
وفيما تهامه البعض بسوء الاخلاق قال اخرون
انه ابدى ثقه بنفسه تفوق ثقه رئيس الحكومه
[موسيقى]